DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
WAS JOE BIDEN RELEASES HIS FIRST
AD, HIS WIFE TRIES TO HELP.
>> YOUR CANDIDATE MIGHT BE
BETTER ON, I DON'T KNOW,
HEALTH CARE THEN JOE IS BUT
YOU'VE GOT TO LOOK AT WHO'S
GOING TO WIN THIS ELECTION MAY
BE HAVE TO SWALLOW A LITTLE BIT
AND SAY OKAY, I PERSONALLY LIKE
SO-AND-SO BETTER BUT YOUR BOTTOM
LINE HAS TO BE THAT WE HAVE TO
BEAT TRUMP.
>> Greg: SWALLOW A LITTLE BIT.
TALK ABOUT A RINGING
ENDORSEMENT.
PLEASE VOTE FOR MY HUSBAND, HE'S
REALLY NOT THAT BAD.
I GET IT, IT IS HARD TO NAIL
TRUMP WHEN EVERYONE HAS A JOB
AND THE U.S. ECONOMY IS HUMMING
AND PEACE IS BREAKING OUT
EVERYWHERE.
WHAT IS LEFT?
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
HYPOTHETICAL.
FIRST, THE PSYCHOLOGICAL.
>> RESTORE THE SOUL OF THE
NATION BATTERED BY AN ERRATIC,
VICIOUS, BULLYING PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
BECAUSE THINGS ARE GOING WELL,
THE TAG IS ABOUT AN EMOTIONAL
FEELING TOWARD A PRESIDENT.
COULD YOU IMAGINE ANY OTHER
COUNTRY SAYING PLEASE GET RID OF
OUR LEADER BECAUSE HE'S A BIG
MEANIE OR COACH SAYING JOE IS
TAKING US TO THE CHAMPIONSHIP
BUT HE'S A JERK, SO CUT HIM.
IF THIS WERE A GOOD IDEA, EVERY
BRILLIANT MP WOULD BE OUT OF
WORK.
THE DEMS CAN'T SEPARATE
TRANSFERS NARROWLY FROM HOW WELL
HE RUNS THE COUNTRY.
THEY CONFLATE WORDS WITH DEEDS
AND THE REAL WORLD FROM THE
TRUMP SHOW.
IT SAVES THEM FROM HAVING TO
COME UP WITH ANYTHING BETTER,
WHICH THEY LACK.
THERE IS NO BIG WAR BUT IF WHAT
-- THERE IS NO RECESSION YET BUT
WHAT IF THERE WAS ONE?
THE BIG RHETORICAL.
IT'S BEEN ON OUR HYPOTHETICALS
FOR THREE YEARS.
OUT AT ANY MOMENT, UNSTABLE
TRUMP COULD LEAD US SOMEWHERE
REALLY BAD AS HE LEADS US TO
SOMEPLACE GOOD.
AS YOU SCAN THE CHOICES FOR
PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE TO FEEL BAD
FOR THE DEMS.
THEY ARE PLAYING PIN THE TAIL ON
THE DONKEY IN A ROOM FULL OF
ASSES.
>> Dana: THAT WILL HURT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I DON'T EVEN KNOW IT
IT MEANS.
>> Dana: YOU'VE NEVER PLAYED
THAT WESTERN MARK PIN THE TAIL
ON THE DONKEY?
>> Greg: I HAVE BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE JOKE I MADE.
THEY ARE TARGETING FEELINGS.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHAT ELECTIONS
ARE ABOUT.
I IMAGINE THEY CHOSE ERRATIC,
VICIOUS, BULLYING BECAUSE THEY
WERE POLL TESTED AND FOCUS
GROUPED TO DEATH IN WOMEN ARE
SAYING THESE ARE THE THINGS WE
CAN'T TAKE.
THE ELECTABILITY ARGUMENT THAT
HIS WIFE WAS USING IS THAT THAT
IS USUALLY MOTIVATE PRIMARY
VOTERS.
IT MIGHT MOTIVATE YOU IN A
GENERAL ELECTION IF YOU'RE LIKE
ONE OF THE OTHER BUT A PRIMARIES
LIKE YOU WANT YOUR PERSON.
YOU'RE GOING TO GOT THERE AND
SUPPORT THEM.
SHE'S BASICALLY SAYING HE'S THE
MOST ELECTABLE SO VOTE FOR HIM.
IN HIS AUNT, IT IS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
HE'S TRYING TO PUSH OUT A
CHARACTER CONTRAST.
THE OTHER THING IS HE'S THE MOST
ELECTABLE NOW UNTIL WARREN AND
SANDERS, ONE OF THEM HAS TO GO.
WHEN THAT COALESCES, THEN THEY
WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
ELECTABILITY ARGUMENT.
>> Greg: THEY WILL MOLD
INTIMATE TWO-HEADED SOCIALIST
MONSTER AND THEY WILL HAVE 30%
SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY GO IN FRONT
OF BIDEN.
>> Jesse: I DON'T EVEN THINK
IF YOU ADD THOSE TWO UP THAT IT
GETS TO 30.
I THINK IT'S MID-20s.
>> Greg: I THINK IT'S 35.
>> Jesse: I WOULD BE SURPRISED
IF IT'S THAT HIGH.
I THINK THERE ARE MORE MODERATES
THAN THERE ARE CRAZY LEFT-WING
SOCIALISTS.
I AGREE WITH DANA, I THINK
ELECTABILITY AND EXPERIENCE ARE
OVERRATED IN POLITICS.
HILLARY WAS THE MOST EXPERIENCED
AND SHE LOST.
BARACK OBAMA WAS THE LEAST
EXPERIENCE AND HE WON.
DONALD TRUMP WAS COMPLETELY ON
ELECTABLE AND HE WON.
YOU CAN THROW THAT OUT THE
WINDOW.
RIGHT NOW THE EMERGENT PUBLIC
BELIEVES SOMEONE THAT'S
EXPERIENCED IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
JUST SEEMS LIKE AN INSIDER
THAT'S BEEN THERE THEIR WHOLE
LIFE.
OR SOMEONE THAT'S ELECTABLE LIKE
JOE IS SOMEONE THAT THE PUNDITS
PREDICT IS ELECTABLE AND THE
PUNDITS ARE ALWAYS WRONG, EXCEPT
ME, OF COURSE.
BIDEN'S BIG STRENGTHS ARE HIS
ASSOCIATION WITH BARACK OBAMA
AND TWO, HE'S CLINGING
DESPERATELY TO THAT MODERATE
LANE BY HIS FINGERNAILS.
HE HAS BEEN PILING UP SO MANY
GAFFES AND HAVING A LOT OF
TROUBLE WITH THE SMALL DONORS
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO CUT BACK
HIS SCHEDULE BECAUSE HE'S TOO
SLEEPY.
HE'S NOT INSPIRING.
HE DOESN'T DRAW ANY CROWDS.
LISMORE AND HAD ABOUT 12,000 THE
OTHER DAY.
BIDEN I THINK HASN'T CRACKED
1,000 LAST COUPLE MONTHS.
SO HE'S ALSO PROMISED TO GIVE
HEALTH INSURANCE TO ILLEGAL
ALIENS, ELIMINATE COAL AND
NATURAL GAS AND RAISE TAXES FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS.
REALLY, REALLY BODY BLOWS IF YOU
LOOK AT A GENERAL ELECTION.
SOMETHING HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THIS WINTER WHEN
SPYGATE IS FINALLY EXPOSED,
WILLIAMS.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER,
WHAT DID HE KNOW AND WENT TO THE
NOID.
IF YOU KNEW ANYTHING AT ALL IF
HE DIDN'T, WHERE WAS HE?
>> Greg: YEAH, WILLIAMS!
>> Juan: ELECTABILITY IS THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR DEMOCRATS
COME OUT OF THIS ANY QUESTION.
CNN HAD 60% OF DEMOCRATS SAYING
WE WANT SOMEONE WHO'S PROVEN IN
THEIR ABILITY TO WIN AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK TRUMP IS MAD AT FOX AND
FOX POLLING --
>> Greg: NOT ME, JUAN.
>> Katie: YOU ARE HIS NEW
FAVORITE, GREG.
>> Juan: HE IS MAD AT ME.
AND FOX POLL AND WE HAVE FOUR
PEOPLE BEATING HIM BUT THE KEY
FOR DEMOCRATS IS CAN YOU BEAT
TRUMP?
THIS IS INTERESTING HE IS UP
RIGHT NOW IN THE POLLS.
BEFORE HE RAN THIS AD, HE HAD
INCREASED IN THE CNN POLL BY
SEVEN POINTS, NOW UP TO 29%.
SANDERS AND WARREN AT LIKE 15
AND 14, ABOUT 30% OF THAT.
THE KEY FOR ME IS LOOKING INSIDE
THE NUMBERS AND WHEN YOU LOOK
INSIDE THE NUMBERS, WHAT DO YOU
SEE?
MODERATES, OLD DEMOCRATS, SOME
OF THE YOUNG FOLKS BUT REALLY
STRONG NUMBER OF CONSERVATIVE TO
MODERATE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
BACKING BIDEN.
THEY SEE HIM AS THE ALTERNATIVE
TO TRUMP.
TRUMP IS THE BULLY, HAS THE GUY
WHO WE CAN SEE IS A NICE GUY,
JOE FROM SCRANTON WHO CAN TRUST
AND WHO THEY THINK THIS IS GOING
TO BE A REFERENDUM ON TRUMP,
THAT HE ALLOWS IT TO BE A
REFERENDUM ON TRUMP BECAUSE JOE
IS NOT OBJECTIONABLE.
>> Dana: CAN I MENTION, ALSO
KAMALA HARRIS HAD HAD THAT BUMP
AND THAT A COMPLETE COLLAPSE.
>> Juan: THE OTHER GOOD NEWS
AND THAT POLL IS FOR
JULIAN CASTRO WHO IS NOW MADE
THE DEBATE STAGE COME UP TO 2%.
AND YOU SHOULD KNOW HE HAS PUT
FORWARD AN ANIMAL WELFARE PLAN.
>> Greg: FANTASTIC.
>> Juan: WATCHING "THE FIVE."
>> Greg: THIS IS A PARTY, IT'S
2020, 100 YEARS AFTER WOMEN
GETTING THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND
THEY'RE GOING TO COALESCE BEHIND
A WHITE MALE BORN IN THE
1940s.
>> Katie: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Greg: THAT IS WHEN THE WAR
TOOK PLACE.
>> Katie: YOU SAID
ELECTABILITY IS IMPORTANT,
THAT'S TRUE BUT IT'S ALWAYS
MISCALCULATED.
ROMNEY IS AN EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE
WHO BEAT BARACK OBAMA.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT A NICE GUY.
IT'S A MYTH THAT HE'S A NICE
PLAYER ON THE FIELD.
HE'S ACTUALLY PRETTY BRUTAL WHEN
IT COMES TO THINGS HE SAYS ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
IF YOU CAN'T GET AN ENDORSEMENT
FROM YOUR WIFE OR ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT AND SHE HAS TO SAY, HIS
HEALTH CARE PLAN, THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE AMONG ALL VOTERS, IT MIGHT
NOT BE GOOD AS ANYONE ELSE IN
THE FIELD THAT YOU SHOULD VOTE
FOR HIM ANYWAY?
THEY HAVE TO TALK ABOUT WHY HIS
POLICIES ARE BETTER FOR
DEMOCRATS IN THE COUNTRY.
IF THEY ARE NOT GOING TO,
ELIZABETH WARREN WELL.
>> Greg: MY PREDICTION IS LIZ.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT IT WAS
KAMALA.
>> Greg: LIZ HAS THE ENERGY.
I WILL CHANGE MY MIND FOUR TIMES
FOR THE EVENING IS OVER.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
HAVE YOU GOT PLANS?
>> Jesse: I DON'T SEE HOW
BIDEN GETS IT.
I THINK WARREN RIGHT NOW HAS A
LOT OF MOMENTUM.
>> Juan: THE THING ABOUT
HAVING THE WIFE DO IT, YOU WANT
SURROGATES WHO CAN INSPIRE YOU
AND UPLIFT YOU AND IT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF DESPERATION.
YOUR WIFE DIDN'T ENDORSE YOU.
>> Dana: VACANT PLAYER DECENT
AND IMPORTANT ROLE BUT WHEN YOUR
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTB
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTE
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTA
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTS
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTG
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTO
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTD
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTH
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTE
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTR
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTS
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOT,
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTI
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOT'
FIRST STATEMENT IS HE MIGHT NOTS
LIKE JOE BIDEN WHEN HE'S ON
STAGE.
>> Greg: IT IS THE THING THAT
DANA SAYS.
LOOK FOR THE DOG THAT ISN'T
BARKING.
SHE IS TALKING.
OBAMA ISN'T.
>> Dana: HE'S NOT GOING TO